hey everyone what is going on we're here
to talk about the oneplus 10 pro 5g this
is gonna be my full review of this phone
i've had it in my hands for the past few
weeks i've been testing the camera
system primarily against the oppo find
x5 pro which is essentially the bigger
brother to this smartphone as well as
other android phones out there so we're
gonna go into a full depth review but
here's my cliffnotes version of this in
case you don't have time to watch this
entire video but we hope you do i think
this is one of the better android phones
of 2022 now it's not the best in terms
of the specs out there there are other
smartphones in the android ecosystem
they probably have better camera specs
but with this hasselblad ecosystem built
into it it really does give the
photography aspect a lot more fun and
interesting options to play with you got
10 bit color in this you got your x-pan
mode you got your hasselblad pro mode in
this you got 150 degree mode if you want
to get some of those shots as well um ak
video you can do a lot of great things
and the color science is actually really
good you are going to have to work with
some of the files a little bit to get
exactly what you want but i've shot with
hasselblad cameras for a number of years
and i see a lot of resemblance from
using the x1 d2 and the x1d for that
matter and i see it in this uh
smartphone system this is a very
impressive setup so besides the camera
system i really like how this phone
performs i mean got the snapdragon 8th
gen 1 processor in this which we're
seeing all the latest android phones out
there it's blazingly fast it works great
for my day-to-day tasks um no hiccups no
stuttering nothing whatsoever this has
been an enjoyable phone to use them with
a 5 000 milliamp battery i'm getting an
all-day charge out of it plus you got a
quick charger inside the box 80 watts of
power going into this bad boy so you can
recharge this in no time flat anyway
with that let's go more to a deep dive
on the oneplus 10 pro 5g
[Music]
so let's talk about the oneplus 10 pro
5g now the weather is pretty bad out
here so we may have to interrupt this
review to get to a safer spot or become
dry but nonetheless let's talk as much
as we can right here and now
it is a very handsome looking phone now
the color i have is the black color it's
a matte sort of uh texture to it but it
doesn't feel very sticky to the hands
it's very smooth almost slippery feeling
so i would highly recommend getting a
case or using the case that comes inside
the box that's one of the great things
that oneplus does is they do include a
silicone case i wish more phone
manufacturers would do such a thing but
oneplus has done that for you now in
terms of the display it's an ltpo2
amoled display it's a beautiful display
awesome colors to this 6.7 inches in
terms of its dimensions but it is
relatively taller more than wider so it
does feel really good in the hand but
has slight curvature on the left and
right of the display i feel this design
is a little bit passe i like a more flat
display so you don't get those
accidental touches that you can
sometimes get on phones
i haven't experienced much of that with
this phone per se but i use the silicone
case for the most part but i can see
with using this naked that those touches
might come into play i know uh oneplus
has built in some software inside of
this to sort of reduce that but i just
feel better with a flat display that's
just my personal opinion now also in
terms of the display i do adjust the
colors a little bit more to kind of mute
them because out of the box they're very
vibrant and very saturated that's when
the beautiful parts of the amoled
displays but it's not realistic
so if i'm editing photos or taking
photos i want a much more
nuanced tone to my images or when i'm
taking them so i know exactly what the
colors i'm getting out of camera are so
i do tone those down and you have the
option to do that inside the operating
system now talking about the operating
system for a second here this is a
really kind of i mean this os is really
streamlined and it almost feels like
stock android for the most part which
oneplus has always been really good at
and i like that because there's so many
features inside of this phone you don't
want to get inundated with the overly
like what's the word i would try to
fight like a skin that's got so much
going on inside of it that you just get
lost in all that design and they've done
a really good job with it the wind is
coming zach is about to blow away
and i'm about to blow away as well
yeah this is really windy we're testing
out our mic system here as well to make
sure this holds up who knows uh the
phone is still in my hand which is a
good thing but anyway going back to the
os on this i mean it is really
streamlined really fluid and i really
enjoy it and there is no hiccups this is
a very
fast
fluid phone to use fluid is a word that
i will use a lot throughout this review
because that was the word that stood out
in my mind as soon as i started using
this phone everything's just it feels
good it's smooth
um there's no that there's none of that
those
hiccups and
pauses or reboots or anything i never
feel any of that using this phone
whatsoever so if you were on the fence
and you may never use the oneplus phone
do not be they do it they make a really
good phone and the operating system is
awesome as well so let's talk about the
battery in this phone you get a 5 000
milliamp battery in this and depending
on the refresh rate you want to have on
your display this can last you all day
now of course you have an 80 watt
charger inside the box
which oppo and oneplus are known to do i
mean they're basically the same parent
company right you're just
subtle nuances in the and the uh the
phones but you're getting some of the
same accessories and this charger is
lightning quick this device speaking of
storage has 256 gigabytes of onboard uh
storage on this with 12 gigabytes of ram
and of course like the oppo find x5 pro
you can also increase the ram i believe
it's like vram we can go from 12
gigabytes up to about
19 gigabytes to max it out if you want
to do that speaking of performance let's
talk a little bit about i mean gaming is
okay i don't game a lot on a smartphone
but for my usage
it works well and i'm just a very casual
gamer but for me primarily my focus is
on the cameras uh as you guys know i do
a lot of camera reviews on this channel
and i love hasselblad cameras i
absolutely love them and i love the
partnership that they've done with
oneplus or bo vivo et cetera et cetera
et cetera
and
i gotta say as i mentioned earlier in
the cliff notes version of this review
is the camera system is a lot of fun to
use you have x-pen mode you have the
hasselblad pro mode on this you got the
hasselblad color sciences which are
absolutely awesome you got a 32
megapixel front-facing camera on this
now again 32 megapixels
you really get 32 megapixels no it's
pixel binning but you do get a like a
much sharper
uh image coming out of that
unfortunately you do not get 4k video
coming out the front-facing camera so if
you're worried about that
sorry folks i think samsung is one of
the only ones that's doing it thus far
in 2022 with the newer phones again if
you're recording for tick tock or
instagram you're not going to use 4k
anyway but one of the camera features
that i really enjoy out of this phone
and i mentioned this in my opal find x5
uh camera comparison against the xiaomi
and the samsung is the x-pan mode now if
you've never shot with x-pen it's
essentially a 65 by 24 aspect ratio
almost what imax is and there was a
camera that hasselblad made in
conjunction with fujifilm a number of
years back the x-pan the x-pan ii and
then there was the tx1 the tx2 from
fujifilm which was essentially the same
camera which sort of gave you this
panoramic ability when you're shooting
film and you get that sort of simulation
here the rain is coming in here zaki
we're going to hold through this right
until i finish my quit and
you can shoot in color or in black and
white the images are absolutely awesome
here are some sample footages now before
the hair gets wet and i look absolutely
like let's get out of the rain zach
[Music]
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if you leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
call us dedicated reviewers here we just
got drenched in the rain but we're back
talking about the oneplus 10 pro 5g okay
let's talk about the camera system on
the back of this thing you got a 48 for
the wide and eight for the telephoto and
a 50 megapixel for the ultra wide and
the ultrawide is cool because you can do
150 degree photo to get sort of that
spherical photo if you like those things
it's kind of a gimmick it's not
something you're going to use every day
but it's fun to play around with and
explore that now you can shoot in 10-bit
color and you can also shoot in the 50
megapixel mode of the 48 megapixel mode
for that matter um you have the options
to do that inside the operating system
of the camera setup and it's relatively
easy to go with and the 10-bit color
does enhance the colors quite often now
of course when you do upload it to
social media some of this does some of
this compression does come into play so
will you notice a difference when you
upload it hard to say but it is uh you
will notice if you're going to lightroom
or going to capture one you want to play
with your photos a little bit you'll
notice that there's the colors just look
a little bit better so this is a
relatively a good bargain if you want to
shoot an expand mode black and white or
color again
you don't get the full feel of an x-pan
camera but you save yourself thousands
of dollars in the meantime so in the day
it's what comes out and what you post
online that matters not exactly always
the tool that you hold in your hand some
may disagree or somebody agree with that
but those are my thoughts on this um
besides that though the video quality is
also really good on this again you're
gonna get a little bit of overexposure
on this we'll show you some samples
shooting at 8k video 4k as well and it
does a decent job is it going to be the
best video camera that we're going to
see on any android smartphone probably
not i would say samsung might have the
edge on that but you do have a lot of
versatility in this and i think for a
lot of people out there they're just
going to be shooting videos for tick
tockers instagram reels or facebook this
is going to be more than adequate for
you guys the mic systems on this are
pretty good the audio is well so this is
a really decent all-around phone and
i've watched other reviewers out there
that talked about this thing well it's a
really good android phone but but but
when you look at the butts they're
really kind of nitpicking so to me to
round this review up i'm going to say
this i'm going to say that the oneplus
10 pro 5g if you have the proper 5g
network to utilize this phone if you if
you're into that you're going to really
like this it does come at a price point
that's a little bit higher than what
we're used to getting from oneplus
they've kind of got into that flagship
mode and it really is coming close to
the oppo find x5 pro 5g which does beg
the question do you go with the oppo or
do you go with the oneplus because
essentially they are the same phone now
the oppo has slightly better camera
system on the back of it and
you know a ceramic back versus
this a gorilla glass here but
it's up to you you know few hundred buck
savings could mean a lot to somebody or
it could be inconsequential to you teach
their own but anyway i like this phone i
would say honestly it's one of the
better android phones i've used thus far
in 2022 and i would say give it a shot
you know people are worried about the
service and the support and i think just
check on your market to make sure that
there is something for that here in
singapore lazada sg is the exclusive
distributor for this so you can contact
lazada which they're very good at
handling these things and they'll help
you out with that but do check out in
your local respective markets to find
out as well anyway those are my thoughts
on the oneplus 10 pro 5g let me know
your thoughts in the comment section
below is this a phone you're looking to
pick up you're still on the fence
let us know we're going to get out of
this rain right now because there's
lightning crackling right behind zacky
he's not looking to turn into the flash
that doesn't happen any of us here so
we're going to bail out with that guys
take care stay safe subscribe to the
channel follow us on facebook and we'll
chat to you very soon take care zacky
let's get out of here man this is
absolutely nuts but if i can get a
lightning shot that would be epic man
epic for the review
and x-pan mode that would be awesome if
i could do it dude that would be so sick
we're waiting for the lightning to
strike thunder
lightning don't hit us just give us
lightning in the ocean
i'm gonna get soaked waiting aren't i
yep
it's not good
[Music]
you